all right welcome back everyone so today
is the second lecture on our sequence of
complex analysis so I want to give you a
little bit of motivation for why we're
doing complex analysis because it can
get a little bit dry especially in the
middle before you learn how to do really
cool things so so there's a number of
reasons we're going to be able to use
complex analysis to solve really
interesting partial differential
equations so for example if I have like
a disk of metal and I'm applying some
kind of a fixed temperature at the
boundaries then I want to find not only
the steady state temperature
distribution at time infinity but I
might also want to figure out what are
the transients in the temperature
profile over time as it equilibrate and
this is the kind of problem that we need
complex variables to solve ok complex
analysis is also just good for you to
know it's like knowing calculus even if
you haven't taken a derivative or an
integral in a long time it's still good
to know the general formalism of how to
deal with complex variables and the
complex plane I don't do complex
integrals on a daily basis I haven't
done one in years but it's still
fundamentally important to know kind of
how math generalizes from real numbers
to complex numbers and it is really
important if you want to do PDEs by hand
which a lot of you are going to do at
some points during your career so that
said complex analysis can be both very
deep and interesting and also somewhat
boring and so what I like to tell people
is when you're studying math that you're
not exactly sure why you're learning it
or what it's good for yet which is true
of a lot of fields of math I think of it
like eating your broccoli or going to
the gym like not everyone loves doing it
but it's definitely good for you and it
lets you view things that you want to do
later ok
so unfortunately that's a terrible
preference to call this the broccoli
lecture but
but this is actually some pretty cool
stuff so I want to just start out with
an example of complex numbers arising in
everyday life because it's kind of
interesting or at least maybe not in
everyday life but in science-fiction so
who can tell me why physicists say that
we can't go faster than the speed of
light like what are some common reasons
why we can't go faster than the speed of
light right people used to say that you
couldn't go faster than the speed of
sound but they were full of it because
horses couldn't go faster than the speed
of sound but that would they had no good
physical reason to believe that what's
our physical basis to think that you
can't go faster than the speed of light
right so there are essentially changes
to the geometry of space and time that
make it so you would need infinite
amounts of energy time would slow down
infinitely slow and your mass would grow
infinitely large so the large mass is
the cool part at least for me so you
have this Lorentz dilation factor where
you have your mass if you're going super
fast so you're fast mass is equal to
your rest mass if you're going zero
speed like basically our masses right
now divided by one minus your velocity
squared divided by the speed of light
squared okay so this is there's also a
similar term for time and for energy C
is the speed of light and it's super
fast so the basic idea is that as your
velocity approaches the speed of light
this fraction approaches one and your
rest mass gets divided by zero and your
mass blows up to infinity which is not
good right so this is one of the reasons
why physicists say that you can't
possibly go faster than the speed of
light or at least we can't go faster
than the speed of light but are there
any loopholes to this your masses
if you're massless you could maybe go
the speed of light okay
what are some other loopholes so I like
that so let's think about messing with
the mass what other things can happen to
the mass to make you go faster than the
speed of light sorry um I was going to
say I keep your driving this well then I
know they're talking about systems that
will warp space-time so that I can
respect to local space you'll be
stationary but the bubble is going to
travel at the speed of light okay so
this is Star Trek stuff what do they
call those particles and Star Trek
tachyons so so a physicists in 1965
proposed that you could okay so we mere
earthlings are limited to velocities
that are less than C because if we
passed through C our massive blow-up but
what if there are imaginary people with
imaginary mass and their velocity is
always fixed at greater than the speed
of light you could potentially have that
and you would have one - something
bigger than one so a lot like a negative
number so you would have an imaginary
mass and you also couldn't go through
the speed of light like you would also
be bounded to always be faster than the
speed of light because if you went lower
or equal to the speed of light you would
have infinite imaginary mass and so
these hypothesized particles go faster
than the speed of light always and have
imaginary mass and just recently there
was a paper published this isn't a new
idea this has been around for quite some
time that neutrinos may in fact be
tachyons because it actually is more
consistent with our measurements if they
are going slightly faster than the speed
of light it's a little bit dubious I
don't think many people believe it but
it's an interesting idea so this is just
one place where complex numbers to come
up in physics there's lots of others so
if you look at the Schrodinger equation
for lasers and optics you have lots and
lots of imaginary complex functions that
are important we're also going to get
complex functions and heat transfer
and wave equations like when you play
guitar lots of complex functions come
out of that partial differential
equation okay so now we're going to talk
about math so last time we saw some
complex functions and for the most part
they were like what we're used to seeing
you know you could have sine of a
complex variable Z you could have Z to
the power n we didn't talk about square
root of Z but we'll talk about that a
little bit today and so something that I
want to talk about is what are called
roots of unity and this is a nice
intuitive way to understand why some
functions of the complex plane are
multi-value they have multiple function
values for a fixed single value of z so
if I said what is the square root of +1
what would you say right
not just 1 but plus or minus 1 ok so we
know that there are two solutions to
this square root function and each of
them 1 squared gives us 1 ok so if I
draw these in the complex plane I have
the point plus 1 and I have the point
minus 1 ok so the square root of 1 has a
radius which is still 1 but the first
kind of principal square root has a
phase angle of 0 and the second square
root has a phase angle of pi ok and the
idea is if I wanted to take so let's say
I wanted to take the third root of +1
are there any guesses for how I would
figure out what the third root of +1 is
sorry one of the physical to buy so one
with a phase angle of zero would be one
of the solutions okay so you're down one
with the print the principal cube root
of one is going to be one just like the
principal square root of one is one and
you're right that's also the same as
having a phase angle of 2 pi what did
you say
okay so I could take this you know this
is also equal to two pi or four pi or so
on so I could take this phase angle and
divide it into thirds so I could have my
theta equals to PI thirds and theta
equals four PI thirds and the idea here
is remember if I take complex numbers if
I have you know Z equals R e to the I
theta and I take Z to the third power I
get my radius cubed and I got e to the 3
I theta right and the whole idea of a
cubed root function is that it should be
the inverse of the cubing function so
any one of the cubed roots of one when i
plug it into this formula I should get 1
e to the you know zero zero phase angle
or e to the 2 pi if you like so what we
can do is we can take two pi I and
divide it by three and we get the first
sorry the second cubed root of negative
one and if you verify you have e to the
you have 1 times e to the I 2 PI over 3
if I take that to the third power I get
1 e to the 2 pi I which is just 1 so
this number when I cube it I take my
angle and I multiply it by 3 and I get
back to 1 so does this make sense when
you take a complex number and you
multiply it by itself or you cube it or
square it or whatever you take its phase
angle and you multiply it by the power
that you're taking that variable to so I
have this phase angle 2 PI over 3 and if
I take that to the third power then I
get 3 of them and I'm right back to
positive real 1 radius 1 phase angle 2
pi ok so this is one of the cubed roots
of plus 1
this is the other one you can verify
that if I go around three times at 4 PI
over 3 this is 1 2 & 3 all right if I
take 4 PI over 3 times 3 I get 2
rotations it brings me right back to
positive 1 now I haven't proven that
there aren't any other roots of positive
1 but that's something we'll do in a
minute okay questions about this before
I actually write down the mass more
formally
okay what if I asked you to do the cubed
root of negative one okay so what is the
cube root of negative one how would I
like what's the general procedure for
how I would figure this out
what's one of these solutions just some
number negative one so negative one
times negative one times negative one is
negative one okay good so one of my
solutions is negative one what are a
couple of my other solutions
I mean so this thing has a phase angle
of Pi so my guess is that if I took
something with a phase angle of PI
thirds then that would be a cubed root
of negative one because if I take that
to the third power I pick up you know PI
thirds to PI thirds PI and I'm right
back where I want which is negative one
another solution is down here and notice
that these are all kind of equally
spaced 120 degrees in each of them and
this one's at e to the I 5 PI over 3
okay so the roots of unity or the roots
of negative unity or whatever are always
going to be equally spaced in phase
angles so the fourth root of one is like
this these are the fourth roots of one
if I had the fifth roots of one then it
would look like a Pentagon
they would all have like 72 degrees
between them or something like that
and there's always exactly as many roots
as the denominator of the fractional
exponent one you know this is 1 to the 1
over 4 so there's 4 roots of this ok a
little bit interesting so maybe I'll
just give you the formula for this or
all I'll give you the basic idea of how
you would obtain this there's a homework
problem where you're essentially taking
functions to a fractional power so
you're going to have some function like
Z to the I root 2 or something like that
you know this is some function of Z and
I should tell you the homework is
probably going to come out either later
tonight or early tomorrow morning so
you'll have some function Z which is
like Z to the I square root of 2 and I'm
going to want you to take this function
and write it as something like a plus I
B where a and B are real or I might want
you to write it something like a times e
to the I B where a and B are both real
functions ok so the way that we would do
this if you have a general function Z to
the a
so in the complex plane we can always
say that Z equals e to the log Z this is
a trick so this is a trick to figure out
why you have these weird multivalued
functions when you have strange powers
of a so in the complex plane we have Z
equals e to the log Z these are inverse
functions so this is guaranteed to
always give me back exactly Z and so if
I take my function Z to the power a
that's the same as e to the a log Z no
problem and so I'll do one quick example
so if I have an example where a is
rational like M divided by n so for
example all of the cases we just did
were examples where a is rational like
the cubed root of one a would be 1 over
3 the 4th root of negative 1 a would be
1 over 4 ok these are rational exponents
of my complex variable Z so what we're
going to do is we're going to look at
this formula when this exponent a is a
rational number it's sort of dividing on
the division of two integers ok so we
have Z to the M divided by N equals e to
the M over N log Z ok that's e to the M
over N and remember last time we had an
expression for log of Z in terms of the
length of Z and the phase angle of Z so
we have e to the M over N log Z plus the
phase angle which was I times the
principal theta plus 2 pi K
and K could be any integer you could
plug in K equals five or two or zero or
negative one doesn't matter this is
still the log of Z so it's got a lot of
infinitely many possible phase angles
that could have imaginary parts and so
I'm going to break this up into a real
part and then the complex phase part or
maybe I'm going to break it up into the
radius and the phase angle because
that's always a useful thing we want we
always want something like our e to the
I theta okay so this log of Z the length
of Z I'm going to call this my radius
this is e to the M over N log of my
radius just using R for the length of Z
times e to the M over N I ate ax times e
to the M over N I 2 pi K because I got
these three terms that build up into
this function Z to the power a ok this
is a purely real valued function log of
a real number is a real number M over N
of a real numbers a real number and e to
the real numbers a real number so this
thing is you can do some math this is
just e to the log R which is R to the M
over N okay and then these are also
pretty simple you have e to the I M over
N theta P plus 2 pi ok
okay so this is this is a nice
expression for the function Z to a
rational number I take the radius of my
complex variable Z and that radius is
simple I take that real number to the
power M over N easy but the angle these
the angle of these roots of unity for
example are given by this expression
okay so if I take let's say that a say a
equals 1/4 okay
then I would take e to the I over four
times my principle angle of Z and then
any additional two PI over four times K
so let's say I take a to the equals
one-fourth and let's say I'm taking the
fourth root of positive one so what's
the phase angle of positive one zero so
theta P for positive one is 0 so I have
e to the I over 4 0 plus 2 pi K ok and I
can let's just try a bunch of case so
for K equals zero so this equals you
know K equals 0 K equals 1 K equals 2 3
4 dot dot so what k equals 0 I get e to
the 0 okay for K equals 1 I get e to the
PI over 2 e to the I PI over 2 for K
equals 3 for k equals 2 I get 4 PI over
4 is just PI e to the I PI K equals 3 I
get 3 PI halves and something
interesting happens when K equals 4 so
if I plug in 4 here I have 8 pi divided
by 4 is 2 pi and I'm back where I
started
I to the 2 pi which equals e to the I 0
so I have four unique angles and then at
K equals four and back to K equals zero
they're the same the same angle and if I
plotted all of these I would have they
all have radius 1 to the 1/4 which is
one and they have angle 0 PI over 2 pi
and 3 PI over 2 0 PI over 2
I three PI over two those are my fourth
roots of positive one okay
these four numbers are my fourth roots
of positive one and we use this formula
to get them okay so you could take the
19th root of five plus seven I shouldn't
be any problem at all you could find the
radius and the phase angle of five plus
7i and then you could go about taking
the 19th
you know fractions of two pi and you can
get essentially for any complex number Z
and any rational power a you can figure
out easily what those roots of that that
function are using this formula okay
the homework problem is going to be a
little bit more involved so you're going
to essentially be looking at this basic
basic idea where you plug in Z equals e
to the log Z into some function like
this okay any questions about this roots
of unity business
okay call me son
yeah definitely so well for example in a
complex in a differential equation right
we're used to having things let's see so
if I had something like X to the fourth
you know minus x equals zero or X to the
fourth plus x equals zero I'm going to
get a bunch of repeated roots of plus
one and then I'm going to get a bunch of
fourth roots of negative one here right
all of my lambdas are going to be fourth
roots of negative one
and those fourth roots of negative one I
think it's this may be rotated a little
bit each of those is an eigenvalue that
has a real part and an imaginary part
some oscillation and some transient
decay or growth so for example in
differential equations these roots of
unity come up as your eigen values all
the time so roots of polynomials are
closely related to you know roots of
unity here there's a whole field of
algebra dedicated to thinking about
which polynomials even have roots that
you can write down by hand in terms of
like square root of two and fifth root
of pi and things like that and it all
eventually comes back down to these
roots of unity so that's one one
practical application okay and so part
of the reason I'm telling you this is
because your functions can have multiple
values remember in our logarithm
function in our log function we had
something like in the Z plane
we had some R and theta and when we take
the log of it in the you know W equals
log Z plane then we have a lot of
different solutions of this infinitely
many okay so the real part is equal to
log of our log of the radius but then
the imaginary part is equal to theta and
theta plus 2 pi I and theta plus 4 pi
theta minus 2 pi and so on you have all
of these solutions ok so some really
interesting things happen in the complex
plane so let's say that this is the real
part maybe the imaginary part and the
real part of Z and let's say that this z
axis is the imaginary part of log of Z
ok so we're going to do a thought
experiment and the thought experiment is
let's say that I start at you know Z
equals 1 so it has a phase angle of 0
it's a real number and then let's say in
the Z plane I just start making circles
I start I literally just take my Z and I
go around in circles okay what happens
to my function log of Z as I go around
in circles yes some super weird stuff
happens I start at zero phase angle of
zero and I increased it PI over 2 pi 3
PI over 2 to PI but I don't go back to 0
now I'm at 2 pi plus PI over 2 3 PI 3 PI
plus PI over 2 4 pi and I keep
increasing my phase angle I'm not sure
if I can draw this
but basically I get this kind of spiral
staircase looking thing that goes on
forever in both directions okay and this
is kind of an interesting idea in
complex variables you you know these are
real branches real kind of levels of
this function log Z so there's the pup
the principal level the principal branch
from 0 to 2pi and then there's the
secondary branch from 2 pi to 4 pi and 4
pi to 6 pi and so i'm not going to go
into a lot of detail on this but in the
notes i have one page called branch
points and branch cuts and the basic
idea is that sometimes we want to take
this multi value function and we want to
pick a branch maybe from 0 to 2pi and we
want to just define our function to have
values between 0 and 2pi so when our
logarithm you know crosses to pi we
might want to start back at 0 again this
is a trick that we use in complex
numbers so that we can take multi valued
functions and just isolate kind of a
well behaved piece of it or one of the
output values and we do this all the
time so for example when I take square
root of 1 oftentimes I'll just say it's
1 sometimes I forget the negative 1
because this is the principal square
root
just like 0 to 2 pi here is the
principal logarithm ok but there are
more values of this logarithm just like
there's more values of square root of 1
ok I'm not going to harp on this because
this isn't going to become important
until a you know a little ways from now
but I do want you to be thinking like
let's say that I'm doing an integral in
the complex plane right we we found that
it's really useful to do contour
integrals so let's say that I do some
contour integral of some complex
function around a closed circuit some
complex functions like the logarithm if
I do an integral around a closed circuit
I might pick up a factor of 2 pi
okay and this is going to be one of the
most important ideas and complex
analysis is that closed integrals in the
complex plane can give you extra factors
of phase an extra 2 pi I if my function
has this weird multivalued property if
it's something like Z to the 1/2 or log
of Z so there are some weird functions
in the complex plane that are multi
valued that have lots of branches like
square root of 1 or 4th root of Z or log
of Z and when I integrate closed curves
in the complex plane I can pick up an
extra 2 pi phase angle when I integrate
so that's what all that we're going to
talk about on Friday and Monday but I
just want to seed that thought in your
heads
ok you can get this weird thing where
you pick up extra phase angle and so
what I'm going to do today is show you
so these are weird functions maybe
they're not just weird they're very
special functions and interesting
functions where if you integrate over a
closed contour that circles z equals 0
you pick up an extra 2 pi I in phase ok
these are very interesting functions
we're doing a closed integral of those
in the complex plane gives you something
like a 2 pi I so today I'm going to tell
you about the property that defines all
of the boring normal functions that
don't do this all of the functions were
used to seeing
and this is really really really closely
and intimately related to vector
calculus which we covered at the very
tail end of last quarter so remember
that there were conservative vector
fields and conservative vector fields
had the property that if I did a closed
contour integral then I would
essentially integrate to zero okay so if
I had some you know vector field F and I
did some you know closed integral of FDS
I would get zero so there's an analogue
in complex numbers and these are called
analytic functions F of Z okay now I've
been kind of wrestling with how I want
to introduce analytic functions to you
because you could take an entire ten or
fifteen week course on analytic
functions it would be terribly boring
but I want you to know that most
important properties of these functions
because it's really release 'fl so first
I'm going to tell you what they look
like what kinds of functions they are
they are because that's what matters so
these are things like polynomials
you know Z to the integer n you know Z
is a positive integer or you know sums
of polynomials Z to the three plus Z to
the 4 minus Z to 5 things like that
they're functions that have convergent
Taylor series so they're functions where
a Taylor series exists
so those are things like e to the Z sine
of Z dot dot notice that the logarithm
is funny so log of Z has a Taylor series
most places but where does it not have a
Taylor series so this has a Taylor
series most places ie
Z not equal to zero but it doesn't have
a cannot at Z equals zero so this
function log Z is an analytic function
everywhere except at the origin which is
why if I take my integral around this
function log of Z as long as my closed
integral contains the origin really
weird stuff happens but if I had a
contour integral out here and it didn't
contain the origin it would integrate to
0
because the function log of Z is
analytic out here it has a Taylor series
expansion it's a finds a conservative
vector field ok so these are the basic
properties of analytic functions that I
want you to know about all I'm saying is
that analytic functions are things that
were used to polynomials things with
Taylor series nice smooth functions that
don't have bad singularities so let's
say that so no so you can't be analytic
not analytic at or very near a
singularity so like 1 over Z not
analytic 1 over Z squared not analytic
at least at Z equals 0 because that's a
big singularity and when I say
singularity I mean something that goes
to infinity yeah
so yes I mean Z not equal to zero thank
you yeah okay okay one last definition
of what it is to be or not to be
analytic is this is probably the most
intuitive one is a function is analytic
if it's literally an expression of Z as
a whole and not just a function of x and
y the real and imaginary parts it's a
little bit weird but I'll show you what
I mean so f is analytic if it's a
function of Z and not just a composite
function of X's and Y's this is a little
bit of a weird definition but things
like you know Z squared is clearly a
function of Z I don't need to think
about x and y but I could have a
function so f so things that are not
analytic sorry I'll answer your question
in just just a minute
at least at you know Z equals 0 1 over Z
log of Z Z to the think Z to the one
half is probably not analytic as equals
0 but you should verify that I'm going
to put a question mark next to that one
maybe that'll be on the homework another
really good one is let's say that I had
F of Z equals X minus iy ok this is the
complex conjugate function right Z is X
plus iy the complex conjugate of Z is X
minus iy this is not an analytic
function because I can never write this
as a closed form expression of just Z I
need to write it in terms of the
components of Z x and y not an analytic
function that's what I mean by this
condition
or you have weird functions like this
like you could cook up some function
like x-squared plus log of Y minus
square root of Y divided by X and
chances are it's not going to be a
closed form function of Z those are not
analytic they're not analytically
expressible in terms of Z that's what
analytic means okay you had a question
our functions analytic in certain
regions or are we describing the
function is analytic functions are
analytic in certain regions yes in
functions that are analytic and all
regions are called analytic functions so
e to the Z sine of Z coast of Z
polynomials are analytic everywhere log
of Z is analytic most places but
definitely not at zero because it has a
singularity at zero I think that you
know 1 over Z is analytic at lots of
places
that's not analytic but it ok we'll get
into the details of this later and I'll
give you tests where you can tell if a
function is or is not analytic so you'll
be telling me soon whether or not these
are analytic cuz I don't remember ok
but these analytic functions are
extremely interesting because what
analyticity gives you is the ability to
do calculus it guarantees that you have
some basic notion of smoothness so I can
do integrals and derivatives I can do
calculus on functions that are analytic
and notice that I have essentially said
that the only things that aren't
analytic are things that don't have
Taylor series or have singularities
right you can't do calculus if you have
singularities and if you can't do
calculus then you probably can't write a
Taylor series because it's written in
terms of derivatives so what I want to
do is give you an example of a weird
function that's not analytic and then
I'm going to motivate a condition for
when something is analytic ok so weird
function not analytic
is the complex conjugate okay so I have
f of Z equals okay we're going to define
it as z bar and that equals X minus iy
and so what I'm going to try to do is
compute the derivative of this function
with respect to Z so I want D I don't
want I want DF DZ and so we're going to
try to take the derivative of this
function with respect to Z because if it
was an analytic function of just Z I
should be able to take the derivative
with respect to Z okay so this equals
the limit just like in calculus as Delta
Z approaches zero of F of Z plus Delta Z
minus f of Z divided by Delta Z no
problem just the definition of the
derivative using limits you should be
able to do this ok and this equals the
limit as Delta Z goes to 0 of Delta Z
bar divided by Delta Z that's what
happens if you plug this into the
function you get Delta Z conjugate
divided by Delta Z but this thing has
real an imaginary part so it equals the
limit of Delta X minus I Delta Y divided
by Delta X plus I Delta Y ok now if a
derivative exists in the complex plane
it should be the same no matter which
direction I take that derivative no
matter which direction I let Delta Z
approach zero right would be weird if it
didn't so what we're going to do is
we're going to take the derivative at
the point 0 starting on the real axis
and then we're also going to take the
limit starting on the imaginary axis and
we're going to see if they're equal ok
so let's say that 1 is approaching on
the real axis and 2 is approaching on
the imaginary axis so one we're going to
take the limit as Delta X goes to 0 of
just this thing if we start on the real
axis that we don't have
these I Delta wise and that's limited
Delta x over delta x equals plus one
okay the derivative approaching from the
writes on the real axis is plus one now
let's take the derivative coming from
the imaginary axis so limit of Delta Y
goes to zero and now we don't have these
Delta X's we just have minus I Delta Y
divided by Delta I Delta Y and this
limit is minus one this is terrible this
function has weird derivatives weird
limits from different angles and it
turns out that any angle you choose is
going to give you a different derivative
okay so this is kind of what I mean by
not being analytic this is definitely
not analytic because I can't take a
derivative my derivative is not defined
okay so a fifth condition of what it
means to be derivative to have a
derivative is that F is single valued
single valued and has a finite
derivative F prime I should have a
derivative and that derivative should
exist no matter what direction I take
that derivative this is kind of the
useful definition of analytic because I
can actually calculate whether or not
this thing is true and I might also have
an additional condition every math book
disagrees on this I might also want this
derivative to be smooth in a small
neighborhood of that point when I'm
defining an elasticity I like that one I
think it's nice to have smoothness okay
excellent
I have five minutes left which is just
enough to tell you the most important
thing in this lecture which are the
conditions so that you can tell if a
function is or is not annulled
so again this is called the Cauchy
Riemann condition Koshi
anything with Cochise name is a big deal
not quite as big a deal as Euler but in
complex analysis he's the defined most
things and Riemann was I think Gauss is
maybe only student okay so for F of Z to
be analytic what do we need so the
derivative must be the same regardless
of which path I take okay F prime must
be the same regardless of path if I
don't get through all of this before the
bell rings I want you to read this
carefully and I'll finish it on Friday
okay so we're going to say F of Z equals
the real part it's a function of you
know X and y plus the imaginary part
which is a function of x and y and what
I'm going to do is I'm going to take
this limit I'm going to say DF DZ equals
the limit as Delta X goes to 0 and Delta
Y goes to 0 in any combination at any
path I like of Delta u plus I Delta V
divided by Delta X plus I Delta Y ok so
we're going to do the same thing we did
in the last example we're going to
approach on the real axis and then we're
also going to approach on the imaginary
axis so if I approach on the real axis
then I don't have an i Y and I only have
u of X comma 0 V of X comma 0 so I have
D F D Z equals limb of Delta X goes
zero Delta u plus I Delta V just divided
by Delta X and this is partial u partial
X plus I partial V partial X U and V are
functions of X this is partial u partial
X plus I partial V partial X if I
approach on the imaginary axis I have DF
DZ equals the limit of Delta Y goes to
zero of this okay and that equals so 1
divided by I as negative I so I have
negative I partial u partial y plus
partial V partial Y now what did we say
has to be true for a function to be
analytic these have to be equal okay I'm
not this isn't a proof this is just a
kind of cartoon I'm not proving that if
these are equal then this is definitely
true no matter what path you take but
trust me it is if I take if if I take
the derivative of the x-axis and I take
the derivative on the y-axis and they're
equal then this function you can take
the derivative at any path at that point
and they'll be equal so for these to be
equal I need the real parts to be equal
and the imaginary parts to be equal so I
need partial u partial X to equal
partial V partial Y and I need partial V
partial X to equal minus partial u
partial Y these are the Koshi riemann
conditions they're extremely important
if i had thought of using color I would
have colors and if these equations are
true for a function Z a function of Z
then that function is analytic so what I
want you to do is try this out for e to
the Z and sine of Z and log of Z and
show that those functions are analytic
the first two are analytic
everywhere and log of Z is analytic
everywhere except Z equals zero okay
this is extremely useful this is the
condition that tells us that you can do
calculus on certain functions okay we'll
talk more about that on Friday